a group of migrant women is coming
forward with claims that they were the
victims of
unwanted and unnecessary medical
procedures at a federal detention center
in georgia
22 women shared graphic stories in
support of a lawsuit filed by court
yesterday alleging poor treatment
maria vitriol shows us how many fear
retaliation for speaking up
they say they're at risk of imminent
deportation and a warning maria for some
of our viewers
that the story and the description of
what they're saying can be very
disturbing and graphic
good morning to you though
good morning gail that's exactly right
immigration customs enforcement says
they deny all claims of retaliation and
they say that they did not speed up any
deportation of these women but
this new complaint describes allegations
of dozens of procedures at patients
and also an independent team of doctors
that was hired by lawyers and advocates
say
was medically unnecessary
i think that because we're immigrants
they believe that we should just be
mistreated
yanita asked us to use only her first
name because she's talking to us from
inside the irwin county detention center
in a new complaint and declaration filed
thursday
she alleges dr mahendra amin improperly
performed a transvaginal ultrasound
after she told him about her
hysterectomy the pain was excruciating
her declaration reads
and felt like being raped have you been
sexually assaulted before
yes do you know what this feels like yes
and it did bring down a lot of those
memories back
the team of outside doctors who reviewed
yanita's records along with thousands of
pages for other women treated by dr amin
say there is a disturbing pattern of
women pressured to have surgery that was
not medically indicated
and to which they did not consent dr
maggie muller is a member of that team
these are procedures that carry risk
they require
sedation they require anesthesia in the
operating room
um and when you talk to these women they
really had no idea that they were going
to have these procedures done
so there is a concern from the review
board
that more damage could have been done to
these women that they even know about
certainly if that is a profound concern
that we had
attorneys say attempts to obtain full
records for all the women have been
blocked
we do not have all of the records all of
the records
for all of these women are controlled
and held
by the federal government lawyer elora
mukherjee represents two irwin detainees
there is a culture of brutality
and dehumanization at the irwin county
detention center
women are terrified that if they speak
to the federal investigators
that they will be deported in
retaliation for speaking out
that's exactly what hiromi navarro says
happened to her i
am in mexico because i spoke up because
they deported me for being outspoken
she claims her deportation was expedited
leaving behind two daughters
after raising concerns about medical
procedures at irwin
and i always teach my daughters even the
two-year-old
my eight-year-old especially speak up
baby speak up to not be afraid do not be
afraid love
speak up there are multiple ongoing
investigation into these claims and a
lawyer for doctor i mean says he's
cooperating with all of those
investigations he has repeatedly denied
any wrongdoing
in these cases and says that he treats
his patients with the utmost care and
respect
yesterday a dozen or so congressional
delegates democrats
sent a letter to federal investigators
asking them to protect at least
18 of dr amin's patients saying that
they are in detention right now and they
are fearing for deportation so they are
asking for that protection of them
because they could have crucial evidence
in this case
anthony an alarming story maria thank
you very much